um did you not even write any [ __ ]
bits for the new movie yeah i did i
wrote one that i really wanted to do to
have a swing
with a toilet seat and then you know
that trick you do on a swing we swing as
high as you can then you do a flip out
of it
and at the height of my flip i was gonna
[ __ ] upside down
that's epic yeah and it's simple you
know and they you think that we could oh
yeah we'll just shoot that real quick it
won't take very much but they never did
it
i wrote some other ones too that was the
one i really wanted though but yeah i
wrote some and just didn't happen i mean
we know we had so few filming days for
this one compared to any of the other
ones it was like 30 days of filming
and no travel all in and around la only
so there are a lot of ideas that didn't
happen
yeah seriously right especially ones
that you were like planning to do was
there a trip that was planned or like
internationally they were never gonna
they were never gonna charge before
that's because of covid yeah he had
fused but i'm saying like even when
they're when you're writing the movie
before covet hit there was no like and
then we'll go fly to india
he said if you if you guys want to go
somewhere write enough ideas that are
good to make us want to take you there
yeah so i would always said that yeah
i've always tried you know i want to go
somewhere i'm like yeah i write a bunch
of new zealand ideas uh-huh you know but
um
you uh
that was it that just the one swinging
[ __ ] idea no i had a bunch of ideas but
i'm not just going to blur them all out
here for everybody
i feel like that one's a goner now
but yeah i wrote it down and i don't
know if they just didn't want a [ __ ] in
this movie they got present [ __ ] in the
movie um yeah
accidentally
man that stunk i was like 100 yards away
i was so far away i'm like what is that
smell like oh look at that preston [ __ ]
in his pants i was nowhere near and i
could smell it wow somebody said uh
god preston had been so bummed about
like that happening i'm like what about
getting that epic gold footage yeah i'm
like i'm like dude like he was about to
do some dirty dancing thing where like
he could get hurt like
and he didn't have to get hurt he got
the footage like he's stoked for sure
it's hilarious part of the movie yeah
but you think he was about to get hurt
i mean whatever like it would like it
i bet we man what was yeah
got out of any pain
right he just
and we were nowhere near any place to
clean up though either that's another
problem i don't know how he got that all
cleaned up but yeah it's called stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on amazon and type in stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude